[Music]
on tuesday march the 22nd
all right and item one is apologies do
we have any apologies
okay no
all right item two conflicts of interest
any conflicts of interest to be recorded
for minuting
okay
confirmation of minutes
item 3 from the meeting of 16th of
november on your pages
to 11.
[Music]
are you all across those
so
any issues before i move and ask for a
second to confirm was a true and
accurate record
there was a small correction to my job
title it had a water environment officer
rather than water environment advisor
that's very minor
can can we um
uh
address that and correct it please
taya
or whomever
okay yes counselor we will do that
thank you
um i'll um i'll move that the minutes of
um
uh the committee of the 16th of november
be confirmed as a true and correct
record
can i have a seconder
welcome councillor barnet
um can i have a seconder
uh counselor blackie
and i'll put well does any apart from
the correction that sophie's just
brought up we're on minutes councillor
barnett any corrections or
clarifications or whatever apologies
madam chair zoom wasn't working for me
yes join the club darling
same for me madam chair sorry about that
that's all right
okay i'll put it all those in favor
please say aye
oh don't say i raise your hand um
those against um
put your thumbs down
um i declare it um
passed um
thank you
um
all right item four matters arising from
those minutes
any matters arising
all right okay
item five
reputations in presentations
any of those
um no
so we move to item six
which is
um the report
um the camera of enhancement fund review
uh and or just before i invite sophie to
take us through it
i'd just like to say that there's been
some
concerns about
this um
particularly the fencing policy and i
think
we're going to um have a
um
a context and a process put around it
that um will um
will address people's who concerns that
have been
discuss with me but in saying that i'll
pass over to um sophie to take us uh
through it thank you sophie
remember to take myself off mute
yeah so thanks um cheer stuart um yes as
you mentioned it is um something that
i've drafted up a few changes to the
recommendations that i can do a screen
share shortly just to go just a little
quick run through first just to make
sure we have you know some some
backgrounds
um there was a report in to the november
land and water committee meeting which
talked about the strategic direction
where we
chose to have some catchment works as
well as the in-stream works for the
cam over enhancement fund and
there was a step of getting um
approval from fish and game north
carolina fishing game and dock before
we changed the the scope of what we
would fund
and so we did have verbal confirmation
from north carolina efficient game but
we never got anything written
um and so just noting making making sure
the quiz committee is aware of that that
i am proceeding on on their verbal
approval
and
uh
that stock was required to have
consultation which i did send through
information about but didn't didn't hear
back so it was approval from fish and
game which i've taken from their verbal
approval and
uh
and then no no feedback from doc has
taken us that's that's consultation
um
yeah so proceeding on with that i've
been scoping out catchment works which
basically just means looking rather than
looking at what's happening in the
waterway itself is there stuff we can do
within the catchment that has good
source control before it actually gets
into the into the waterways
so some of those things are an argelite
trial so special type of uh
what's uh
gravel that you put on the road that's a
clay base rather than your usual river
river run gravel and the advantage of
that the roading team's finding is that
you get a lot less dust so this is for a
trial on marsh road waikuru road where
the
area gets it's a very um it's got lots
of curves and it gets a lot of dust and
a lot of um so there's a photo in the
november report showing the runoff that
we got from that road going into the
into the drain
so because of those issues there we've
scoped up um a trial to see if we can
prevent that dust and and drainage run
off into the cam main stem
um so that's one of the things that's
been scoped up uh then also fencing
probably yes the fencing is what
sandra's mentioned is is the one that's
causing a little bit of issues because
we're trying to be equitable
um
but the and also go with what is
not not not paying people to do
something that is the requirement
but there are a couple of
grey areas or and or there's one
exemption i'm proposing in this fencing
policy
which is for maori owned land
and i do go into some of the rationale
in the report that's particularly
because often you've got multiple owners
in this maori owned land
hasn't had the
ability to raise capital to develop the
land so trying to
um yeah so i could definitely answer
more questions about that that one
exemption um i can bring up some notes
from sanja where she's talking about
some improvements to the fencing policy
in a sec so
um
yeah um
okay so i definitely proposing fencing
um over
um other catchment works such as
planting because it is shown to be a
more reasonable return on investment
if you're trying to trap sediment so you
can have long grass
after the fence that then you know then
prevents the sediment getting into the
waterways so it is a habitat improvement
but it's just a step back from from
being in the waterways
um should i pull up that shed document
now stuart um
[Laughter]
sandra will be fine um
yes yes but well um do you want to see
um what's the
context
of these these editions or ask some
questions
first up
committee members would you like to see
what's what um we're proposing
or maybe try
yeah yeah let's see what your what
the addition is sophie if you can put it
up thank you okay
so i'll start with the recommendations
and
i'm recommending to delete b
to remove b
and
so this is um a point that i hadn't
haven't covered yet but um it's
understood it's correct that we actually
did talk about maintenance works not
coming out of the
actual camera enhancement fund
itself so this is a clarification or a
sort of oversight from myself actually
about
the
we still do the sediment trap
maintenance works that are in the report
but that just the budget will be from
either the drainage maintenance budget
or the
zipper budget which has been allocated
some camera of a
long-term maintenance budget ongoing
because of the awareness that sediment
traps do not emptying every
few years
um
i
have also suggested that we delete
recommendation d
and
the reason for that is that i've got um
quite a bit of feedback from from
sandra and
rather than holding it up until the may
meeting
what we could do is have
the committee delegate approval of the
fencing policy with with changes
um by the chair
now i do have the utilities and writing
manager i think there was a suggestion
from from chris brown
cool and then um sort of feedback from
sandra just to make a bit easier for
everyone
[Music]
can everyone see that all right or am i
i can't actually tell if you've got
enough if that's uh zooming in enough
yes we can i can see that really well
okay perfect
so i could talk through a little bit um
so the
the generally the policy is in line with
ecan that um that their policy that they
will not fund fencing that's required
under the
planned change seven of the land and
water regional plan apart from the
as i mentioned the maori owned land uh
which is possibly something that you can
might
they might have not considered and um
the other question the uncertainty is
ephemeral intermittent waterways
particularly drains
where um now you're required to fence
waterways in our district uh sorry
artificial water courses are district
from plan change seven but there's no
clarity about whether it's ones that are
only
um wet all the time or if you've got
something that that does flow
intermittently is that still required to
be fenced it's something which the even
in development the land
management advisor at ecan has been
struggling to get clarity on from the
ecam planners so we've been trying to
work on that
so point two
that we will continue that we will seek
advice from the land management advisor
who is in development as i mentioned
for our district and also
talk to the landowner and stock owner or
stock controller about what is
appropriate and management practices so
basically not just saying fencing but
also talk about their land management
with them
a quest for an mou with the landowner or
stock controller
and to install a permanent fence
so that is actually i didn't wasn't
clear in the in the report but the
fencing is permanent fencing um when i
say two two wires with posts that's what
um i consider to be
um a permanent fence for for cattle
and then just just a question there
so a sheep fence with one hot wire
across the top isn't considered a
permanent fence because i've seen that
used for kettle too
uh well a sheet fence with one hot wire
wouldn't wouldn't work they would better
get underneath it so that um sheet
fencing is definitely you've got to have
so all the
project the fencing projects had
uh cattle
which don't you know with the two hot
wires um well actually there was a
question mark whether there was ever
sheep grazing at one of the sites but i
think at the moment it's cattle they
just might sometimes alternate and i
haven't checked
um because i mean we we have cattle
we've got a four wire sheep fence and a
hot wire that extends out along the top
so they don't go near the fence
so i see that happen quite regularly
with cattle so you're saying that
wouldn't comply
no no sorry two electric wires for
cattle with no just one electric wire at
the top
uh people do use it but um we're saying
here that that's not enough that you're
gonna have two that's what we're there
just to interrupt that that quote um
uh post and bat and turn erect right was
that's the out of the regulations that's
what a permanent fence must be to
qualify
um as permanent i'm i'm just querying i
was querying that because i'm just
looking at common practice out and
because often people alternate
cattle and sheep sometimes so they have
they put the cattle into places where
they just put the
the wire that's pushed out from the
fence so the cattle can't go near the
fence
um
so i just wondered
yeah
just wondering if
is that making because two electric
wires is kind of expensive for a lot of
people it's
just a query yeah
councillor blackie yeah can i follow on
from kirsten the i'd agree with her um
the way it's written there does that
mean that the offense has to have two
electric wires as well as a defense and
my other um problem with
with electric wires is um if you've got
if if you've got an area we want to
fence off in the middle of a paddock
hundreds of meters from anywhere um how
are you going to get power to it and
you have to go um
solar power units and you're pushing the
cost up i think you know i i hear you
say that that's the regulations but it's
overkill by a mile there's thousands of
cattle in other stock with thousands of
kilometers of ordinary five five wire
fencing all over the um
all over the district
it's it's getting a bit carried away
i can reply that sandra if you're maybe
two yeah so it is um electric wires or
defense it's not saying a defense and
electric wires and i think the when it
says post and batten it doesn't have to
be
i mean i i've always taken this as being
like a firewire five-way or a sheep
knitting fence because battens are not
so common in in the south island for
some reason that's right
um so yeah so that's your sheep fencing
when it says post and bat and this is
written by someone from the north island
probably
and then the two wise for your cattle
and then defense be a deer but the
question is yeah if you have both cattle
and
sheep which is what um
kirsten was ringing up yeah would you
have to have an outrigger as well as the
sheep feds i'd say that the sheep fence
probably would do
the job but you probably you'd have the
kettle destroying it over time if you
didn't have that outrigger hot wire
so in terms of i'm electrifying yeah i
think um
the options that i did check all the
options if they had had electrical they
already had um electricity in the in the
um nearby
area so they could that you know from
the from the stock um people with the
stock already so it just wouldn't that
wouldn't be an issue there but there's
something to think about i probably
wouldn't propose a system for electric
wire
if it was solar or
required a lot of
work to get power to the site it would
either have to be we're going to go for
your wire fencing or just not propose
that project
um councillor atkinson
thank you madam chair look
well the discussion's good about what
fence is what what is the regulation
because that is what we will have to
enforce
that is
well i understand
but i mean
sorry yes the point point being i think
in the context of the whole lot is full
discussion with so that we secure a
permanent fence that protects whatever
work the cam fund
um decides to um fund
i got no problem with the with the
direction we're going in what i do have
a problem with this if the regulation
says one thing
and we go and talk about
not stringently
sticking to that how do we force
anything else that we're trying to do
so um and and i'm actually with kirsten
here because i think that there are much
there are much better ways to fencing
than what the regulations is so i think
we have to go back
and as so she said may very well be
written for the north island but we need
it written for
christchurch
and specific if we need to so that we
can enforce regulations that
are
absolutely correct for what we need to
do because we're going to look stupid
trying to talk to people about
regulations and then when it comes to
fencing we're going to do something
different
yeah just a bit more confusing there are
actually two different sets of
regulations
the plant change seven regulations which
currently just say stock exclusion and
they don't even identify what that is so
um they could be talking about a
temporary fence with a hot wire
for for stock that are break feeding for
example and then the rma stock exclusion
regulations have have more of a
definition so
um sometimes it's it's the national
regulations that are more stringent and
sometimes it's the plan change seven so
plan change seven supply applies to
artificial water courses
but it has no setback and then the rma
regulations have
a setback if you've got a waterway
that's more than a metre wide that's a
natural waterway
i think just to interject i think in the
context the context of this that
we would
i would hope take advice from
ecan and
to work out what and what is appropriate
in this context
jared you would like to comment
i just wonder if the better way to deal
with this is to remove the very last
section of that um sentence and just to
comply with the
uh rma and environment canterbury
regulations um
and then it becomes a bit more enduring
and
so it's effectively has to still be a
permanent fence
so i'd say
as defined by rma stock exclusion
regulations
and end ecan
full stop um to remove the description
of exactly what it is
um and then it's it's uh future proof
yeah well done um everybody happy with
with that um amend well slight amendment
raise your hand and thumbs
cool
thank you
okay and just
if you wanted to carry on with it
um with going so there's fencing here
um oh i can't move it can i do you want
to just carry on sophie with taking us
through that
yep sure so uh
there are a couple other points that i
pulled out from an email from
chris that chris brown that you'd passed
on sandra too to him as well which are
similar but um and add to what was
circulated already to the
to the committee
um
so oh yes i didn't mention that yet
there'll be a memo report similar to
what um came to the committee today
about
fencing projects planting projects in
the future
uh but yeah you were keen to add in um
for a check by
a development for all projects before
approved by the committee added a
statement to the fencing policy to
identify that all cases
that we have to contribute to the
enhancement of the camp river so this
putting in the
the vision the purpose of the policy
what we're seeking and
consider any project holistically so
this is where you're saying that um you
know going above and above and beyond
what's required in the land and what a
regional plan
is it a fair summary sandra um because
it came through it came through chris
brown so i i've tried to also just tweak
it to make it a little bit more legible
so you might have lost something
in the translation
well it's it's it's embellished it
considerably and i i think the point i i
was
wanted to get across and and it makes
that i am comfortable with
um
funds from the cam fund to be used for
fencing
um as long as um on private land
as long as there's an enhanced
ecological and in-stream habitat outcome
over and above what would um have been
got if in fact the
regulations the existing regulations
were pursued to the
letter of the the law and that we have
um
uh we involve
um eken in helping us through that
because iken has far more um experience
on the ground
um with um talking to landowners who may
be required to do certain things through
a land management plan and haven't got
it underway and that's compulsory in a
year or so
and we do have a permanent fence
we have a written agreement with the
land owner or stock controller so
they're agreeable to all this
um
and that um you know basically we've
exhausted the hierarchy of remedies
before coming to this fund and we
guarantee
a far better environmental outcome by
using um the chem fund for fencing
and and part of the project that's where
i'm coming from and um
i i think it's it's covered here what i
would like to see um
and i'm quite um
quite happy to move that the fencing
policy
um
be approved subject to
working the context and the process in
with discussion with me as chair
and that that can come back to um
uh well
it can come back to the full council
basically i i think if it needs a tick
off or your if you're happy
councillors to give me the delegation
with um
uh jared to to tick it off then
that's where where i've come from with
it um question
councillor redmond
thanks madam chair
i had my hand up a wee while ago but i
just wanted to clarify
is the fencing we're talking about on
private land or is it boundary fencing
between council owned land and the
adjoining landowner
and if that was the case where does the
fencing act with its definitions
of a rural fence that um
grant sophie could clarify that it's
covered in the um
in the reported there is reference to
where it's the council is an owner on
the boundary and the fencing act applies
that just sits like that
but it's private land i think that we're
talking about in the majority here
um
yeah sophie perhaps you'd like to um
yeah that's correct
so
it is mostly that's the projects i've
scoped out so far have all been on on
private land where they've been
adjoining
a waterway or a artificial watercourse
or in one case there's a large area of
ponding that
wouldn't probably meet the definition
well i'm pretty sure wouldn't meet the
proposed definition for a natural
wetland but
might have
before they changed it and so as a
source a critical source area
thank you
uh well you'll note that the we've been
talking about what what is um
uh item d of the
fund review decision there's also a list
of um
projects
that um you've got in your agenda
uh particular
spending
pages
and i i understand jared has
you'll see here
the
sentiment traps
emptying has been removed to go into as
you see there into the drainage
or the zipper budget
um
i'd like to ask a question about the
argolite roading trial just have a bit
more context cost
because this is a contribution fifteen
thousand
um what's the time frame for um this
happening
can someone um just elaborate on that
please
yep so the
um
the works can happen in the next few
weeks before it gets into wintertime uh
it is part of a greater project that
the writing team has um in their area so
there is some
cost saving and
having the establishment costs being
shared across
plus the
so the running team are putting in eight
thousand um for the drainage what what
they need to do in that waterwork
waterway that's that road not waterway
um is um make sure the water doesn't
stay on the road and it stays in the and
the ditch doesn't also flow off into the
into the waterway so that's where
they're putting in their 8 000 for
drainage improvements but the rg light
also provides a bit of surface
um
i think so jared might be able to
correct me on this um
for
um
it doesn't get as rutted and so it
doesn't move as much it gets much more
becomes much more of a sealed surface
and that's why you get less dust and
that's why you get less runoff
and it should
last longer but um
yeah it's it's come about from my
discussions with the roading team where
we identified
run off into the
um cam from the river um
from the from the road in september
there was a storm event i think that
where we had photos sent to us
and
showed show runoff which was a part of
the november report that we came to lana
water
and that's where we has has been try i
think paul williams might have been
involved with some discussions about
argent trials in other parts of the
district where it's been mainly for dust
control whereas this is also looking at
for drainage
and so what we're actually quite lucky
fortunate that the
marsh road site is an ecam monitoring
site already and i've been taking
clarity measurements for quite a long
time there so we would actually have
ongoing monitoring
of that particular site and it is one
that has been identified as being very
dusty
and you can see the dust going into the
waterway
yeah i've taken photos
in summertime before because i i had
noticed it um
and then all that dust is the river
fines that's the type of gravel that we
normally use
any any questions about that um
i've
been saying thank you sophie and saying
that i do have a
um
i'm a bit conflicted about whether this
um should legitimately come from the cam
fund
when in fact it is a eroding um
improvement
um
and the bulk of it
well
this is a
a contribution to the full cost you're
you're saying that the the other 8k is
drainage improvements that will what
prevent the runoff going into the river
yeah yeah so um there's i should have
mentioned there's also forty thousand
dollars worth of roading work in that
area that the roading team is they have
been funded through kotahi but it is
money that's come into their budget that
it is partly doing flood recovery work
so they're not saying it's it's an
environmental enhancement but that's
where
it is part of
that greater project
so just clarification
what it's 48 000 all up
the world
that the roading team were putting in
for the for the work in that area
not just for the rg light trail but also
other work
to improve yeah so that's why i didn't
the 8000 is specifically what's what's
for waterway
uh improvement
with the drainage improvements
okay any any
any further questions counsellors on
this
um councillor blackie can we go back to
the fencing thing for a minute um has
there been any consideration about um
compensation um what what if we go to a
landowner especially a farmer and say
right and he says yeah fine fence off my
say half an acre but i'm losing half an
acre of grazing i'd like to be
compensated is there any is there any
scope for
well what would happen if they came back
with us to us with that sort of proposal
do we just can we
fund that or do we just say no we no
it's not on the table
so it hasn't been discussed uh any
compensation at the moment it sounds
like we had to have willing landowners
who would
not be asking for compensation
the question is though um
with the permanent fencing and the mou
you know if they did take that fencing
away in five ten years um it's not a
legal document and so
you know if they could say oh it was too
expensive to fence off that bit of land
or the landowner could change
but it's not something unfortunate an
mou can can
can legally be
enforced
um perhaps i'll be really clear that's
not on the table
um counselor blackie i think
uh that's just not
uh we start going down that path um
yeah where would that get funded from so
it's just not all on the table
and i think the projects that are being
scoped for
requiring um fencing that stock
exclusion
um
some of this land is is um
you know
the
the landowner has to be willing
participant
and the use of that land um
is is marginal uh for stock
so
in the light of you know land management
plan requirements that
lifestyle block owners are required now
well in the next couple of years to
to sign up to
[Music]
they're going to welcome
assistants if in fact they qualify
um
for
the cam fund
contribution from the cam fund we want
to see a
a
significant environmental enhancement
so
that's where this fund would to my mind
step in
when all the other avenues through
regulation and some of them are in force
and requires a certain degree of setback
um
if these don't um
aren't able to be delivered without
assistance then that's when
we could step up but as i said you know
i'm comfortable with quite the process
that we've laying out here
that the fund is only going to be used
when in fact all other avenues have been
exhausted and we are getting
as much of a guarantee that we're going
to
um have an enhanced environmental
outcome
that we can
so any other
well are we comfortable with the um the
thousand going into the um argolite
uh trial
uh if i work through the the work that's
here
yes yeah well i'll i'll take that as a
yes and we've got a couple of bank
stabilization works um in table one
um
a couple of thousand dollars worth i was
just going to ask
the south brook
[Music]
below the wastewater treatment plant
is that where it comes out before it
goes into the bit that has been enhanced
that goes through the
supermarket site countdown
pick and save
uh no it's for the downstream so it's
yeah yeah
downstream so it is rural land and
on the north side you've got sparks and
on the south side i've forgotten her
name louise somebody owns it um
yeah so there were quite a few trees
that came down in a storm uh last year
and so the the 2000 is the bank
stabilization part but they actually
that we've got um
cyclone horiz
doing some some um
so out of not out of the camera for
enhancement budget but out of the
drainage budget some other other works
as well
so this work wouldn't be covered by the
drainage budget
uh
no well it could be um i just remembered
sorry the reason that that were that
were involved was because the south side
has actually become an espionage reserve
that's right sorry it was subdivided and
so that southern landowner is it's now
rwd council yeah yeah okay
okay well that clarification is useful
uh is it
is it the same sort of thing for um for
the one above it too
uh the one on the marsh
so that's on jono shelton's land um
so um
[Music]
delight limited is the name of the
company which i think is hilarious um
it's a great name it's a great day for
dairy farm yeah so that's um it is
similar yes it's something that
yeah it could come from from drainage
but it's something that is a bank
stabilization improvement so i'm
proposing that it could come from the
camera enhancement fund
okay
all right and the table two going
through there we've got um
we've got an estimate of some fencing
i'd just like to make sure that
um
we go through the process that we're
outlining that
for this fencing policy that will kick
in before we actually tick this
this off
is that your everybody's understanding
um okay um counselor williams you got a
question
comment yes i yes i have um
in the um four and a half thousand for
the hydrotech cost and it's got um
spoiled disposal fees is that that's out
of it now that's going to be done by the
drainage budget it doesn't come out of
this fund those first two
the emptying is of the first two
sediment traps
are
out of the program of works that now
comes
as uh being uh addressed by the drainage
budget budget but you could ask the
question of jared if it uh as a drainage
question i'll save it for a drainage
meeting then ask a question there that's
cool
all right um madam chair could could the
sheet the screen sharing perhaps be
turned off
yep
thank you thank you
okay so just working through page 16
we've got
some fencing there
we've got a
proposal to
fence off a critical source area with a
enhanced setback my understanding was
is
and this will be confirmed hopefully
with the process that we are ticking
hopefully ticking off
is that um this landowner being the
spark family is not required to
um have a setback of that degree for
that critical source area that's the
photo that's there isn't it sophie yep
correct
okay though you would have hoped that
they would have done that out of their
own um
being a good corporate farming citizen
um and then we've got um bank
stabilization
uh further further down and that's the
extent
of what's proposed here
you'll note that
there is
a need to scope further projects um and
i'm just going to ask jared whether
um
you know the resource to do this further
scoping of other projects
how is that going to be um
bearing in mind that our water
environment advisor um
will only be around for another um
couple of months at the most
so where is this um going to be um
picked up um mr cleary can you um give
us um some idea
um yeah look at
like anything like i think we are
proposing to bring in um a replacement
resource for the water and environment
advisor so that's just subject to a
recruitment process um
as you will be aware that has at times
been a challenge um in in recent times
so um
but we're using our best endeavours to
secure a suitable um fill-in for the uh
for the interim um while the water
environment advises on
um leave and then um so we so our
intention is to provide somebody to
provide that continuity um one of the
advantages of i suppose of you signing
us off today it gives us confidence in
the program that we have got in front of
us so um thank you for that in
anticipation so that um
the most time consuming thing for us is
getting things to this point and then
going back to square one and and there's
been quite a lot of that on this project
today um
so we have got and we've also got um
indicative works for the 22 23 year so
it'll be just a matter of working
through those so we've got a good
starting point um and the ones that have
been identified here
um and going forward that's just a that
would be you know we expect so early
what an environment advisor or the water
environment advises temporary
replacement
um
going forward but i think
we all would agree that it's um it's
really good to start to get some actual
real progress on the ground for this
fund because we've done a lot of um
you know we go right back to when henry
hudson did the work um quite a number of
years ago to give us
guidance um
and
uh but so we have got a
i think short answer yes um our
intention is to provide the resource to
make sure that we can have a good
forward work program and to manage it as
a um
thank you
i'm just um
looking at i'm quite happy to
to move the
recommendations with those editions
um
which i'm not quite too certain about
exactly what um what we're ending up
with but
um
certainly the context and um the
additions that sophie did put up
so um which i think um
summarizes
uh the program minus the um well
includes the program minus the drainage
work the emptying of the sediment traps
includes the road
agolite study
and as far as
we adopt approve the
fencing policy with the context
and the processes that outlined
by those various um
additions that you've seen uh but
basically um coming back with a memo and
report to um land and water or well no
it's to
my delegation in in consultation with um
utilities and roading manager so are you
well i'm i'm happy to move that
can i ask for a seconder yeah
um i'll just speak briefly to it um
very much um in favor of getting on and
doing some work on the ground with this
fund it's been a long time coming as
we've said before but in saying that um
particularly um
on the fencing of projects i think um
i was initially
less than comfortable
with
using
the fund for fencing
while it comes under that
option two of that we approved last year
of looking at the wider catchment work
um i'd also like to see eken did offer
to us um
a process whereby
if we had um in-stream a work that
required a consent that they would look
at
working with us to streamline that
process and i would like to see that if
there are in-stream works that come up
in the scoping
of remedial work that we do take ecan up
on this because they are proposing to
have a streamlined green
consent for rehabilitation work as part
of their 2024 new
land and water regional plan
but
in the interim
i would like um to see work um happen
um i want to see though that
that we exhaust all um
avenues legislative or regulation wide
really in discussion with the land
management advisor and the landowner or
stock controller to make sure that
we get an enhanced environmental outcome
for the river if we are going to dip
into this fund
for fencing um fencing work particularly
so yeah um
that's me um councillor blackie want to
speak nothing to add thank you
um any any other comments from anybody
um councillor mailings
yeah i'm i'm a lot happier with the
recommendations as we've changed them
and that
and they read a lot better now and
for the fact that the the fund will be
used as a backstop whenever we've
exhausted other
other avenues as well um because
you know there's such a lack of funding
for
any of these kind of projects and um we
need to use this one carefully but at
the same time it's really good to see
that
we're finally doing something with this
but i would just like to make one
comment
the sustainability and climate change
impacts guys
anything with this
committee any report has got to have
something down there i mean it's always
about water and resilience and
you know clean water sanitation so um
just just a little a little line would
be great next one thanks
thank you thank you councillor and and
totally
agree um with that um i think that of
all
um of all the um work that the council
does this type of environmental work
does in fact have
sustainability and climate change around
implications and and ramifications so um
yes when when our staff are filling out
that
to say that it doesn't it's just um it
doesn't beg as belief really so thank
you um i'm not proposing to have a right
of reply so i will put those
recommendations all those in favor
please say aye
against
declare it carried thank you very much
and thank you sophie
so we'll move now on to item 6.2 which
is um
biodiversity funding
zipper recommendation
to actually give give some funding to
the waimakariri biodiversity trust to
get them
operational
over to you sophie to take us through it
please
great yep so this is the
first year that we've actually had a
budget um within from so as a earmarked
amount within the zipper budget i should
say
which is under recommendation zipper
recommendation 2.8
for 20 000 a year to be allocated to
community groups for by biodiversity
support
and so the recommendation is for the
waimakariri biodiversity trust which is
a newly formed charitable trust in our
district
it has come out of
the wood of waimakariri water zone
committee and the biodiversity working
group there
with judith roper lindsey who's a
retired ecologist has took the lead to
volunteer to be the chair
and she advertised for trustees from the
community
it was fair to say we had quite a wide
range of diverse trustees who applied
which is actually quite good to her
diverse skill season quite a few diverse
places where they live too so a very
good spread um yeah there are five
criteria in the report which i won't go
through but that is how
i've assessed that they are
they are suitable for the funding and it
should be noted that they um
i didn't look at all truck it wasn't an
open
open fund this year a contestable fund
there was no
shout out for anybody else to be able to
apply which is something that in the
future pending staff resourcing could be
could be good to look at from next
financial year
um but yeah with the the waimakariri
water zone committee for example
as well the key criteria that is
attached to the report um and in itself
there might be some questions about that
because i don't think it's been
presented before
um and it's quite good for this water
zone committee so for this land and
water committee to to know what's um
on the water zone committee's action
plan for the next few years
um and also the other thing to point out
is that this is operational spending uh
there's optics so it really is
organizational support like the
deliverables that are listed
it's not for
um
specific planting project or this many
plants et cetera it is to get them going
for for a coordinator but with the idea
that this will give the organizational
strengths that they can
take to apply for that project funding
and for that capex funding that that
will allow them to
to um be strong and and support others
um i did there was one minor correction
i realized in 5.1 of the report 0.5.1 i
did mention um the report being public
excluded and that's that's that's no
longer the case i was there was just i
was a bit unsure about whether it would
be or not uh so just ignore that or we
can correct that if need be
corrected
yeah no that's good yeah so this will be
circulated there was a point about
circulation to the runanga nwdc liaison
meeting so that's where we this report
will be circulated
and is not not public
excluded um yeah happy to
take questions or
any any particular
feedback
uh counselor atkinson
thank you madam chair sophie i'm just a
bit curious i actually support this i
think this is great
however how do you have a contestable
fund
which we actually
give it to one person
how is that contestable and will we be
taken to task on that by somebody that
no one else has actually had a crack at
a contestable fund
sorry the testable fund is a
recommendation for next financial year
from from there and it's partly because
trying to get the criteria for a
contestable fund and do the advertising
and then to get it
to get it funded is quite a quite a
workload and so this year
um it i i wasn't able to do it
myself
it's something that i've i'm looking at
for the biodiversity either the green
space biodiversity
staff next year or other governance team
have potentially put their hands up
because they do administer quite a few
contestable funds
and there are other trusts where you
could argue that they they're not
there's no one other trust that's a
biodiversity trust for the whole
district but they there are obviously
place based trusts um they actually raku
hurry river care group to haytada
coastal park um those kind of there's
that kind of biodiversity group there's
also um a lancair waibacari lanca trust
which has some biodiversity components
yep
i've got no problem with that what
you're saying is that this year is not a
contestable fund yes yes correct okay
thank you yeah
i basically said this this trust meets
the criteria that i have set and
therefore i am recommending them this
year
okay any further questions
um i do have one myself um on um 1.4
where you
talk about these
deliverables that you that we expect
from
funding
the trust
and 1.4
and
1.4.6 which are
mapping and detailing current
biodiversity initiatives in the region
and website creation um
well
do you think that this trust will be
able to deliver on that and how does it
conflict with what we're doing
internally
um for
the biodiversity
uh initiatives in house
so those um deliverables actually came
from
judith roper lindsay and the trust
themselves as what they were proposing
to deliver so it's something which i
yeah i'd be interested i also don't i
don't want double up so if it's
something that that um would be a double
up um
potentially with the environmental
networking forum works it i'm not sure
that that's something that we could say
that actually there's no point in and
you know we could remove a deliverable
but they're still welcome to collaborate
um or
but it is something that i
when i said you know i made sure that
they were happy with this deliverables
and that's what they proposed so that's
why i put it in there
yes
just to
elaborate um as your um as the council's
biodiversity champion
um the shared resources to gis map um
layers of by well not only um
biodiversity projects but sna and the
whole
the whole raft of um
[Music]
tracks trails um
public land existing projects has come
up um
as potentially something that
the district councils will do
under the umbrella of perhaps regional
funding
um
and i would my own view would be also as
far as website creation
certainly um
a website if this is for the trust alone
but
a website that
enables public access to all these
layers of
information on the biodiversity resource
across the district
um i see that sitting far more
with the
district council's home page
than um
a trust with the resources that we were
we have available to us and and talking
to our
by
our ecologists at the moment bex dollery
this is one of the things that she's
actually um
looking at doing
uh mapping and website creation so don't
want as you say a double up and
and hopefully
we can work um the council
in discussion with the trust would make
sure that wouldn't happen
i mean i'm totally in favor of um the
money going to the trust just don't want
to see that
there is work happening um
by two different organizations for
potentially
a similar outcome
so
presumably we'll
we'll have discussions with them liaison
to make sure that doesn't happen
any comment from anybody
on that no
we should just um
just explain that uh we're looking at
transitioning the support for the
waimakariri biodiversity trust to to the
biodiversity team so biodiversity staff
so bex dollery and and kate steele
uh for um while i'm on opportunity
leaving and beyond uh so
something that um
yeah so bix will be in constant touch
with them to make sure there aren't
gonna be double ups yeah so that will
sit well i think and
but just um that that support for
contestable fund is something which
might need governance or you know just
i'm
i'm not making a call for the green
space team about what they can resource
so just raise that with them
yeah no i'm comfortable
with that level of liaison um
i wouldn't imagine that um
you know the two both our internal staff
and
and the um
the members of the trust
they'll be working closely together to
make sure of an outcome that is um
uh
you know valuable to everybody
okay any no other questions counsellors
all right mover and secondary
anyone wanting to move
i'm quite happy happy to move councillor
atkinson
moves and councillor mealings
seconds
councillor atkinson um any comment well
look i think it's all been said i don't
need to go into it i think it's very
well worth while fund once this is set
up we're
up and running get them up and running
and get it going i think it'll be well
worthwhile
excellent thank you councillor millings
no
and i'd just like to add i think yes
this district will benefit from
a trust that
focuses on
increasing the biodiversity footprint
and providing
advice and all the all the good things
that they um
are in this this vision and um
[Music]
and documentation of this trust so i
think um putting twenty thousand into
get them up and underway
for this year is an excellent use of
that money
so um thank you i'll i'll put um the
recommendation all those in favor raise
your hand
or
against declare it carried thank you
and we move on to
item 6.3
again
our water advice
environment advisor
sophie if you can take us through uh
this um private well study and the
results we've had
from 2021 pages 30-39
thank you
yep so this report builds on reports for
the last few years we've had the 2019
study in the 2020 study this year we did
expand into
two new areas so
originally it was eaten and cast but we
added in carlton and solenoid
and the rationale for adding in those
two new areas was that the areas that
potentially will have an increase in
nitrates from the ecam modelling that
was done and eating casts were suspected
to have some of the highest levels
in the district so that's why they were
originally chosen so just a bit of
awareness that that you know you know we
we're not just randomly choosing areas
and seeing what we get that we might
actually be
looking at the the higher areas um at
least with the open cast
but yeah we did find um
three wells above the
limit for the mav limit for
drinking water standards uh
for nitrate nitrogen
um and they were actually spread out so
one was in cast which we've known about
for the last two years and the same one
tested above this time
uh one was in carlton and one was in the
swananoa area so
yeah
interesting to see that yeah carlton in
particular had a very
big spread of results we had some areas
where you're probably getting
denitrification in the groundwater and
you're actually getting the nitrate
removed
and almost getting no nitrate and then
you had one well as i said that was over
um
yeah so
it
um what else could they uh we i have
supported the owners who received the
advice about being over the mav to to
seek water treatment um and i've just
i've actually compiled a list of
suppliers who we're not giving out
recommendations for water supply
treatment supplies we're just saying
here's a list of people who you
um
could possibly contact because we're not
comfortable
saying you know these are the best
people we don't even use them ourselves
the other way we're helping to support
people is
the areas the booklet the private well
advice booklet which was produced last
year
which goes out with limb applications
for example people with private wells it
does need an update um i've drafted some
text from the water services act 2021
which will need to be put into that
booklet in the future about
the big change there
so domestic self-suppliers
um so people who who had their own
supply
in the past but might have just had like
a granny flat or
where it didn't cross a property
boundary might have been fine but now if
you've got multiple households like in a
farm situation you're actually
considered a water supplier and not a
domestic self-supplier anymore from the
water services act
and that means that there are people who
have duties they don't they probably
don't realize they now have to
to test monitor water and put in more
treatment
than probably what they have currently
so i think that's something really
that this
committee
is would be good to have an awareness of
for the rural community i'm just sort of
as a side side issue to the uh proper
wealth study um there was one correction
um and 1.8 of the reports are not um i'm
not sure which page that is but um
0.1.8
um i didn't say that all 39 wells will
be repeated next year but
i remember there's actually one well
that had filtration for the iron
before they could take the sample and so
unfortunately we're going to remove that
well
from this from the study it was only
discovered after they had received the
sample box and they realized they
couldn't sample before their filtration
unit so i will replace them with another
or some the person who will be worried
maternity leave replacement will
find someone another well to replace
them
um yeah i've got quite a few questions
and hands up so
yeah um i didn't get who was first but
we'll have councillor williams up at the
top of the page
you guessed right i was first
um a question for jared ready to answer
this question
um
should we in recommendation h circulate
to report to the council community
boards
should we be wise to also circulate that
to the
um new water regulator um and let them
realize there could be a problem
out there in the community i know it's
we're not controlling at this stage but
it could get passed on to council so
um
do they need should we
advise the water regulator uh or would
it be unwise to do that i don't know if
jared's comment on that um
yes i think that's a very good
suggestion
and we will do that so um the um we've
already had some good positive
engagement with tomato roi
um and it would be really helpful for
them to understand um
the uh
these sorts of issues so absolutely
we'll send them a copy of this
um and discuss it with them if necessary
so
we should add that to um h as well
speaking in the background here um
just
uh in the swannanoa sampling area i'm
really pleased to see that we've we've
added carlton and swannanoa but um
whilst i can figure out where airton is
and i can see that's in a heavy dairying
area
whereabouts is this one under a sampling
area because i can usually tell from
looking at lines on a map exactly where
it is but i can't figure that out
yeah apologies i couldn't get the
mapping to show the
road names and the the you know the our
ymap system unfortunately takes away the
roads just when i try and get the the
whole sampling area and this yeah so i
was drug uh so it is um that is tram
road going through the middle of it
um and i'm just trying to think of this
it might be two chain road that's the
other obvious one running north south so
when i'm getting it out i can double
check that but um i can send you the
um
i could send you like a
with a um with the roads um but just
more zoomed in and you won't be able to
see the whole area so that that could be
another solution
that would be great because um
yeah i i can see that you know there are
certainly going to be an awful lot of
people sitting around on
you know sitting on wells that you know
we can't say it enough that private well
owners need to actually check them but
looking looking at the results that
you've gotten from those wells it's kind
of alarming
but not surprising so um yeah i'd really
like to
have a bit of a better idea on that
sorry about the background
uh councillor atkinson you were
no
um any other questions
okay um i'd just like to test the
meeting with an additional
recommendation
uh to the ones there
and it is
that we request environment canterbury
and the category district health board
to honor this zipper recommendation and
help fund this water quality the
expansion of this water quality
study
to the 180
wells
that it was originally scoped
to sample
can i um ask for a
to that if there's anyone who wants to
uh second it
um thank you councillor mailings
and i'll just talk to it um
uh
why
district council is um
is paving the way for um study of water
quality in private drinking wells
we are honoring the 2018 zipper
recommendation by putting money into
funding the study which is as you'll
recall first of all been
just 19 or 20 wells and then
we've expanded it up to 39 um in this
over the last three years
our sampling
is
revealing results that are a cause for
concern
and we would have far
better better
understanding of what's happening across
the district if we if the funding was
there to expand the sampling
and there are two other
uh
institutions and authorities that were
part and parcel of the zipper
recommendation and to monitor the water
quality and private oils and that is
environment canterbury and the
canterbury district health board none of
which have put money into
this study
so here i'm just asking that we
ask them to honor that recommendation by
funding
putting some funding into
this study so it can be expanded
and i'd like your support on that um
counsellor um melins do you want to add
anything or um
um counselor williams
yeah um by this recommendation i just
wonder with putting the cap
in front of the horse because um
there's been studies the other side of
the wymack bridge and
we know there's a problem everybody
knows there's a problem what we need is
a solution to the problem there rather
than
actually doing more sampling and testing
and all that drama because it's no use
testing all these wells
finding them all got
problems but we need to know what's
going to happen
um
to some of these wells more so than um
finding the problem so
yeah i've um i've got my
thoughts whether that's the right way of
going about it and we may
probably be looking at um
whether we and that's why i wanted to go
to the water regulator to see whether
their thoughts on the situation because
um the problems got to be solved and
snow is going testing and testing and
testing and unless we've actually got a
a way forward after we've done the
testing so
you know we already know there's a
problem
no we don't
um counselor atkinson
you're muted mate
try that um i probably will support this
but i prefer that it was funding in
totality
um
you know we're funding 39 wells that we
probably shouldn't be doing yes we're
paving the way
at the cost of our rate payers when it
should be spread across the canterbury
rate powers and should be done in
totality so um i'd be more i'd be more
inclined to support this if it was in if
it was a total project
cost because it should fall with
um
uh within ken and as you've just said
that they honor
what is in the plan change
well it
oh any other comments and i'll have a
right write a reply on this one um any
other comments uh council meetings um we
won't be replacing this person with
regard to this with this recommendation
ecan controls discharge land use water
tanks which contributes to this problem
and environmental issues are in their
remit more so than than ours we're being
good citizens by doing this
they need to pull their socks up and
actually do their part and do their bit
and
and it shouldn't be coming from our
ratepayers to be doing this in
totalitaria i agree with what
council their atkinson said and um
you know but at the end of the day
regardless of who pays for it it's good
that it's getting done because there are
a whole lot of people sitting there they
have absolutely no clue whatsoever
what's going on with their water and
because they are part of a council
supply which is looking after it to make
sure that it's good in safe water
they just think it looks nice it tastes
good it's fine but nitrate doesn't have
a taste it doesn't have a smell and
these people are putting themselves in
danger and we need to actually find out
the extent of the problem and and
get to the bottom of it
so
that's why i'm supporting this
yeah thank you any other speakers
um i'll have a writer reply on this um
just to
make the point that um
this recommendation to monitor private
well water quality
came out of the waimakariri zipper
recommendations and it and it canvassed
three parties who who were requested to
to do this
um working together um waimakariri is
the this council is the only one that
has put funding into making this happen
and we asked ecan last year whether
there was any funding um for it they
haven't
and i don't even know whether the
canterbury district health board has
been formally requested and
this recommendation formally requests
the other two parties
to
help fund this study
councilor williams said that we know
this we don't know this at all these are
private wells
where the people that are drinking this
water have no idea of the water quality
they're consuming
this is to give us an indication about
how widespread
contamination of
potential contamination of their water
sources
are
we don't know this there is no study
that will um that has well data that we
are of the level that we're talking
about here and that um sophie's going
out there and sampling as is borne by
the fact that
people
are surprised to see what their
uh the well test um reveals and that we
have
um three wells in this latest sample
that are well over the maximum allowable
value for nitrate so we have a
well-being um
uh directive as councilors
as a council
and that's why we're in doing it and i
congratulate
the rest of us for doing it
but there are two other um partners in
this study
none of which have put any money to it
so
the request is the recommendation is to
request them to do to put some funding
into it and we're not talking
a hell of a lot
but
they need to come to the party because
they also have a responsibility for the
for monitoring the water quality
uh in in this district
um yep uh sophie you wanted to add
something
yeah just to clarify your points under
yet that the ecan groundwater team were
approached
last financial year for this for funding
this financial year
which was declined but they have
provided technical support as an advice
but then the cdhb has not been
approached so econ is a signatory of the
zipper
agreement whereas cdhb is is not but
doesn't doesn't preclude them from from
funding such a study
yeah
so it's a request
to ask
those two parties to
fulfill the recommendation
uh and and add to the knowledge of um
what is um we've got 15 16 000 people
drinking from private wells we need to
have an understanding of the quality of
water they're drinking and we don't at
this point
you've already spoken counselor williams
i was going to
put the recommendation
at this point you've
you've got hands up people have got
hands up
yeah i have i was going to correct um
statement that was all but if you don't
want me to that's fine
well correct a statement
well i'm just saying in the news a
couple of weeks ago there has been some
reports on the other side of the
waimakariri river from us we're not
talking about the other side councillor
we're talking about we are talking about
all waters and each end covers both
sides so there has been reports and i
would envision ours would be exactly the
same as the reports from the other side
but anyway that's cool
madam chair that's not part of this
report indeed no
okay so you've you've we've had a robust
discussion back and forth so i will
i will put the
recommendation as an addition to the
ones
if you're in favor
please put your hand up if not
so we've got
three
four
me
and those against raise their hands
i declare it carried
thank you
um so that's in addition we haven't
actually um
moved well i can now
do we have a mover and seconder for the
full report
which includes um
the additional recommendation and the
addition of tamata
roi
on item eight
uh madam chair i thought you'd move the
whole whole report including yeah
probably i don't agree yeah yeah
yes
my apologies counselors
so in fact that um that vote was um for
the whole lot including the
recommendation the addition
thank you
alrighty
um now we can move on to what do we move
on to we move on to portfolio updates
thank you sophie for your input um on
these three reports much appreciated
um i will just um as first off the
the rank um
talk to uh biodiversity um
and uh fortunately we had a um
biodiversity champions meeting with ecan
yesterday and um beck's dollery was very
welcome she sat in on it which was great
um
and i'll just um bring up the main
points um the champions group are very
keen that a biodiversity implications
on every facet of uh
council's work
is included on the agenda of all reports
as a regular item to increase the
visibility and i'd be totally in support
of that
um
it was
last year there was a um a forum between
council
staff and ecan
talking about the issues with
biodiversity enhancement across the full
region
um they want to continue with they see
regular updates um
staff counselor staff
ecan staff and counsellor and
ta forums as um really productive
uh they're talking as i think i've
mentioned before about
advancing a a region-wide skill resource
unit for um
biodiversity where there are some
territorial authorities that haven't got
any dough and don't do anything at all
in the biodiversity space because they
are
haven't got the rate power base
so
he can talking about a regional
skills resource
they were very interested in the sna
since incentives
uh this is ikea particularly that
waimakariri is doing through its um
uh
its
staff and
district plan
there was discussion about gis mapping
across the region
again a shared gis resource
of biodiversity mapping across the
region um
mapping sna's um
public land existing projects
um
uh water waterways
cycleways trails green space um parks
as various layers on a regional resource
and um we would have something like that
on our own home page
uh as a website uh well as a
presumably a link that you would on our
home page you'd go
into and all this these layers of
information would be publicly available
there was also discussion which um
i'm supportive that we do make a
submission on the
emission trading scheme and the better
incentives
to encourage planting of indigenous
forests and there's various other
um things in that legislation uh
submissions close on april the 22nd and
i'd be hopeful that we would be as a
council
crafting a submission in support of some
of the key issues
in that
in that review
so that's pretty much me any um
[Music]
any questions welcome
no all right we'll go on to um
second which is councillor blackie and
his land-based indigenous reserves
including river margins portfolio
thank you um sandra um a couple of just
a couple of things relevant to land and
water committee um in silver stream in
the western end uh the two bridges that
are that are in the pipeline one of the
bridges has been the funding of that has
been approved already in the annual plan
the second bridge that we're putting in
so we've got a loop and people can get
across the river and come back down the
the other side has been donated by um
from the city um so we've got our free
bridge well as free as a bridge ever
gets um we've still got to pay for
installation costs but the bridge has
been donated and we've got a engineer
doing um the engineering but
either pro bono or for a nominal fee so
that's that's great because you know as
you know these bridges tend to cost 15
20 k a pop so that that's that's a big
phillip for the um
for the silver string group
down at the coastal area on the on the
riverbanks um just a quick um catch up
um pegasus bay bylaw committee met last
week because we're and we're under
review
at the moment uh the three-year review
which vijay has got underway just a
couple of comments about the um
the um karaki area the um
car park there is is has been used by 40
000 cars a year now and a quarter of
those go on onto the beach the the
um
tour tour situation which various
members have been complaining about on
the beach that is that is one of the
things that will be in the review but
mike quant has been away to with talking
with mpi and there's a group of auckland
university students coming to do a
survey as part of a project uh to assess
the whole tour tour sustainability um
situation on the whole beach
uh that's about me i think um let me
just look at my little list
yep that'll do thank you
any questions of councillor blackie
councillors
no well thank you very much
um
move on to item eight which is questions
and i have none and item nine urgent
general business
um
item 10 is
matters to be considered in public
excluded
um
i haven't got any report here so i'm at
a loss so it's on the agenda um can
anyone else
help here
um
it's it's the minute it's being diligent
it's just the minutes of the previous
public excluded meeting i ca i haven't
got those minutes um up on my i couldn't
find them when i had a look
but however
in the absence of being able to find the
minutes
i will move that
well do we need to i'm going to public
excluded to um to ratify those minutes
thank you councillor barnard yes
well
yeah okay
um i will move and
council obama will second that
this committee goes into
public excluded
and this is it